good afternoon everyone my name is dr.
Miller and the SCP were going to be
looking at today is SCP 1991 object
class safe special containment
procedures SCP 1991 is to be stored on a
5 meter cubed containment chamber within
site 19's biological specimens wing due
to the specimens behavior a locked door
is considered to be all that is required
to prevent escape SCP 1991 is to be fed
3 kilograms of cooked and pulped beef
daily water is to be provided by a
trough which is to be kept refilled
constantly containment cells to be
cleaned weekly by d-class personnel
description SCP 1991 is a 2 meter long
quadruped Edman mainly and creature of
unknown species enhanced by the
implantation of cybernetic compounds
both implanted compounds and creature
show signs of damage consistent with
extreme aged poorly heeled puncture
wounds bullets of assorted calibers
embedded underneath the skin burns
comparable to those produced by
Industrial cutting lasers and starvation
SCP 1991 appears to have suffered
psychological damage as a result of
physical abuse or trauma displaying
extreme fear of loud noises rapid
movements and aggression or seeming
aggression by personnel SCP 1991's body
core is roughly humanoid with elongated
limbs of equal length all limbs and in
hands similar to those of a large
primate apart from the presence of
elongated claws the head resembles a
mummified canine skull with elongated
incisor teeth skin resembles decayed
leather with matted fur growing from it
primarily around the ankles and back of
the net SCP 1991 lacks a tail when
recovered SCP 1991 displayed traits of
starvation
including enlarged gut and enunciated
limbs proper feeding while in
containment has been shown to cure said
traits cybernetics consists of a
mechanical collar implantation off
unidentified structure into right for
limb sharpened steel blades replacing
teeth and claws of four limbs as well as
system alterations of unknown usage
collar consists of a metal disc embedded
into the front of the neck possessing a
small speaker array non-functional due
to bullet damage 6 video cameras two of
which have broken lenses and a complex
network of fibers apparently serving as
a linkage or control to its central
nervous system non-functional due to due
to the non-functional nature of linkage
between its nervous system and the
camera network on this shield as CP 1991
appears to be blind the right forlán
structure consists of a pair of
miniature mechanical clamps and an
extending rotary metal rod similar to
the triggering equipment of remotely
operated firearms it is assumed that the
clamps were intended to serve as the
mounting system for such a weapon
behavioral test log 1991 - 1 tests of
SCP 1991 behavior in regards to positive
stimuli supervisor dr. stimulus doctor
saying hello in a normal and calm voice
effect upon subject SCP 1991 having
huddled in the furthest corner of the
containment chamber upon dr. his entry
emerged hesitantly and licked dr.
Johnson's outstretched hand supervisor
dr. stimulus SCP 1991 headed on top of
the head by dr.
effect upon subject SCP 1991 amenity
gurgling noise assumed to be a sign of
pleasure supervisor dr. Freud stimulus
SCP 1991 given common canine chew toy
shaped like a teddy bear effect upon
subject SCP 1991 product I with a four
paw causing him to squeak SCP 1991
proceeded to amid whimpering noise and
huddle against the farthest wall of the
containment chamber until the chew toy
was removed behavioral test log 1991 -
two tests of SCP 1991 behavior in
regards to negative stimuli supervisor
agent stimulus agent saying hello in a
raised and aggressive voice effect upon
subject SCP 1991 proceeded to rapidly
move to the farthest edge of the chamber
from agent and attempted to curl into a
bomb supervisor agent stimulus agent
clapping hands in front of SCP 1991
effect upon subject SCP 1991 whimpered
and attempted to cover head with four
paws supervisor agent stimulus gunshot
from starter pistol into the air outside
containment chamber effect upon subject
SCP 1991 urinated on the floor of the
containment chamber and huddled
twitching on the opposite side of
chamber from the door until ending of
the test history SCP 1991 was recovered
by foundation agents in those 19
following reports of a monster
scavenging from dumpsters in a small
town and cover story regarding vagrants
planted
okay I think that about does it for
today thank you all for listening and
you were all dismissed
goodbye I would like to give a special
thank you to slump god Justin day John
Porter fluffy Pierce M Hamlin white crew
beware 600 my archive curator neck tie
verbal Kody tench cheese whip dips McGee
and oblong dish boy if you would like a
special thank you at the end of each of
my videos on some other cool stuff as
well visit patreon.com forward slash the
Volgin thank you
you